you
[Music]
so let's look at some numbers just from
the US perspective ten percent of the
adult population in the u.s. that's
about close to nine million people are
not insurance insured right they don't
have any health insurance which means
that just going to the doctor's office
is almost out of question unless you
have money to pay out of your pocket and
another twenty eight percent of the
working adults those are so in the u.s.
the way it works is that you need to
have a health insurance through your
employer typically and twenty-eight
percent of those working adults are
actually underinsured again you have to
think twice about going to the doctor's
and even if you did go to the doctor's
office you have to think twice about
spending money on your treatments and
all this is going to affect adversely
the care that you can get even if you
just choose to go to decide you go to a
doctor today you gotta wait somewhere
between 20 to 30 days to get access to
be able to be in a doctor's visit and be
see a doctor something I did not know
until I got into the space to tell you
the truth because my health insurance
has been great so far but that's the
typical wait times that you have and no
wonder that people sort of don't go
follow through the health problems that
they have and they end up waiting for a
long time until the conditions worsen
and we see a lot more visits to the ER
and urgent care over the last few years
and if you if you maintain the status
quo and assuming that we have the
shortage of 120,000 physicians by 2030
these numbers are only going to rise so
we got to do something different about
this whole setup so how does health care
today start for most of us it starts
with using a search engine right the
user Google search engine type our
symptoms check it out and if it is
something that is like oh I don't have
to worry about it stay back or if you're
worried about it you may go into the
doctor's office and even if you're
worried about it you probably don't have
enough insurance and you stay right and
that's 25 million Curie's on search
engine and there are about 1.4 million
of visits to the doctor's office every
day
and a large fraction of those visits are
not probably visits because you have a
health problem
probably because you're afraid and he
saw the Google search engine Google
results and then we don't know anything
that happens between for all those
people in between where whether it's
actually whether it's actually problem
within with their health or not right so
you kind of left here with this set up
so what we think is that we need to
rethink how we are looking at it it
shouldn't be a funnel model we shouldn't
be thinking about how how many people
have health problems here and who should
go into the doctor's office should they
go into the doctor's office it or not it
shouldn't be a problem
we shouldn't be even thinking about it
this way I think we need to rethink how
this should happen I think every page
every user if they need to be at the
doctor's office they need to be there at
the right time and I think that's the
most central part right that's when we
can truly say that we have healthcare is
a birthright if you go with that vision
then it's not going to scale we can't
really replicate the number of doctors
we have and we can't be going to
doctor's office every time so that's
where the vision of how we want to do it
happens the diagram is messed up but so
we have a your own personal health agent
if you will that works with you and the
doctor also has their own personal
health an agent that helps them in their
tasks and then there is a communication
that happens between the two and and you
still have access to your doctor but you
have it only when you really need to do
it right so building all these health
agents that can work with you and can
work with the doctors become central to
how we can scale and the rest of my talk
will be about some of the challenges we
have when you have to build such health
agents so the obvious place you can
start is to say I want to build these
agents that are intelligent in some ways
they can capture data from the patients
from the doctors and be able to make
good decisions that allows you to meet
the doctor at the right time
so to build such systems if you're there
are many components of
play a role and to me when you look at
it so much artificial intelligence point
of view there are only two things that I
should think about in the beginning what
data do I have and what model should I
build right now let's look at some of
the data sources that are available for
us to even get started on this topic the
first one is that everyone should be
familiar with is this notion of medical
terminologies or ontology datasets
though the closest one to the task that
we're thinking about is a sno-med
clinical terms these are basically the
set of all the tokens and vocabularies
that you will use in a clinical setting
right anytime you go to the doctor's
office there are a bunch of things that
are recorded about you and those are all
fall into these clinical terms and then
there is a unified medical language
system your MLS which is basically a
compendium or a repository of all
possible vocabularies that are there and
they allow you to bridge between two
different vocabularies so you could
imagine having a biomedical literature
that leads up to smash data set and a
technical term in mesh data set can be
linked to a clinical repository or
instrument through this IMLS concept so
they form the base of all possible sort
of tokens that you need and then there's
an icd-10 code which is basically the
classification of diseases that are used
and when a doctor writes down your
diagnosis he or she pulls out from this
icd-10 and if you're working in a
billing or insurance these are the codes
that you'll see and many papers that are
related to diagnosis always try to
predict these codes and these codes are
nothing but coming from icd-10 so the
other source of data is electronic
access to medical research so with the
availability of PubMed and other sources
you can have now access to the best in
or the recent research this helps you to
build an air agent that are never-ending
learning right so you have your agent is
actually on top of what medical research
that happens and everyone is familiar
with your health sensor data from your
from your Apple watch or any of these
things where you have a tremendous
amount of data that we collect on a
daily basis
and then the other one that I'm really
excited about is the electronic health
records this is probably the large-scale
patient level clinical data that we have
today right add a patient level the way
we look at this is all your encounters
with your with your healthcare system
gets recorded in these records so the
way we want to look at this is through
up through this timeline so a patient is
not a particular time point but it is
actually some sort of a continuum of
their health patterns and what you get
to see is like tiny insights into that
pattern so for instance here is across
the x-axis or the line is your your time
and then at any point in time you had an
encounter with the health system you
have these vertical bars one could be
that you visited a doctor and they wrote
a clinical note or another time could be
that you had a prescription refill for
which you need to go to the doctor's
office and that becomes another time
point so now think about this data set
for every patient right when you have
this data you can change models you can
think about what treatment works for
this patient is a good question to ask
and we can leverage the electronic
health records because you can look at
other patients who may have who may have
had similar conditions leading up to the
treatment right or it could be what is
your prognosis for a disease could be
something you can learn from this data
as well because you can again compare to
other people on their health patterns as
well now if you take this EHR data or a
patient record and intersperse this with
the data that you're getting from your
from your health sensor data then you
have a full set of everything about you
right so instead of instead of like
these discrete ones you can actually
have a complete timeline of your
electronic health record that can be
there can be used for many purposes to
understand your health profiles the new
kinds of data that's emerging is the
user doctor conversational data with a
lot more things happening on on the web
through email or through messaging
service you start to have a lot more
interaction interaction data that are
recorded between a doctor and a patient
this could be a wise conversation
that can be transcribed later or this
could be something that you actually are
typing it right and along with it you
share a lot of information such as your
photos if you have a dermatological
problem or even your video recording of
your walk posture because your gait has
changed a little bit and you want to be
a wondering why that has happened so
that takes us to the second part so this
is like good glimpse of the data sources
that are available for us to train
models but then now you have this talk
about models so I'm going to start with
Oh building a medically aware dialogue
system I will not be going into the
details of how to build a dialogue
system but rather I'll give you key
challenges that we should think about
right it sure it is not about let's take
this data set here of conversational
data and build a dialogue system that is
not going to really work they're not
going to work because you're not either
is going to be data sparsity that you
would hit soon because not every
condition not every problem is going to
be recorded in these conversations so to
build a truly medically aware dialogue
system there are many challenges and I'm
going to highlight a few first is so the
high-level bit here is that you have a
user and a patient sorry an agent and
you're trying to elicit and provide
information to this agent through this
to the patient and you want this to be
medically ever so it has the knowledge
it has a medical knowledge as some knows
about diagnosis it writes us a bunch of
things let's walk through some of these
so I'm going to take an example
conversation between a real user on a
patient and a doctor and sort of walk
you through challenges when you want to
build this as a as a AI system or agent
right first is the user comes and says
right now my stomach hurts
right which is not a terminology in a
medical concept it should be something
that you map your abdominal pain in a
snowman right or it feels like I need to
do a clean up that clean out there's no
term here right it's it's actually a
bowel movement that a doctor understands
but it's not something that's technical
term and understanding that this is
actually about constipation is something
that a system should learn to identify
and not it cannot be a simple lookup so
understanding
in language and projecting them into
terminologies that I use in clinical
sense becomes very important then the
next one is eliciting medically relevant
information right so when used when the
patient said they have a stomach problem
and they're constipated you need to ask
when was your last bowel movement which
is a simple question because it needs to
tell you that the time it takes and then
also talk about other other things how
is that
well moment and so on but then it
doesn't stop there right because you're
the problem you may be constipated and
it could be just your diagnosis could be
constipation it could be a severe form
such as fecal impaction
or it could be gastrin titers it could
be so many other health problems that
are related to this and to do it to be
able to rule out all of these and
collect enough information this agent
has to be asking other related questions
such as nausea and vomiting if you're an
Aussie are vomiting you very likely to
have gastroenteritis or if you are
Dineen or it could be a diary or leading
up to because you ate food outside right
again a food poisoning could be another
reason for all of this
so to rule out many possibilities and
look at what is the right set what is
the possible diagnosis for this one the
the agent needs to know the size of
diagnosis and be able to elicit all this
information from the patient before
actually making a decision of what
should be the next step for the patient
so so now I'm going to spend some time
just talking about AI for medical
diagnosis but you would ask is this the
problem only if you're building a
conversational agent and the answer is
no in fact doctors can benefit a lot
from having an assistant for medical
diagnosis okay because if you look at
your time scale remember we took 30 days
to get an appointment with your doctor
and you spend only 15 minutes with the
doctor where you got to tell everything
you need to know tell them and they have
to sit a lot of information figure out
what civil diagnosis for you suggest the
next steps that's a lot of things to be
done in 15 minutes and the doctors can't
even personalize their recommendations
for you and in a recent study it has
been shown that the accuracy of a
diagnosis
of a doctor is about something like
somewhere 60 to 70 percent give or take
and it only increases to a 90 percent if
you had multiple doctors suggesting a
diagnosis okay so and the reason for
this is that dr. relies on two one
two cues first is a recency bias which
is how are the patients that are coming
into my hospital with these complaints
what is their sort of diagnosis and the
next one is availability bias which is
what is the available information that
they have in hand they may not be
eliciting more information because they
don't have time they'll just like oh
this is not life-threatening let me give
you some sort of a follow-up right now
for you to work with so just leading up
to these tube is leads to a lot more at
bat diagnosis inaccuracies and it is not
something new it's something that's well
known in fact diagnosis first goes back
to all the way to 1970s the first model
that is built is called mice in which is
focused just on infectious diseases the
idea was that there will be an expert
system these are all models for expert
systems the idea is that there's an
expert system which is basically a
knowledge base and an inference engine
and the doctor can curate this expert
system to get more information okay on
possible differential diagnosis and then
and it's based on it covers about
thousand diseases and about 3,500
findings and the findings that you'll
see in sno-med for instance and it's
based on scientific research so let me
give you an example of what that
knowledge base would look like so here
is an example for like a one particular
disease called alcoholic hepatitis right
so for each one of these symptoms like
the age or whether there was an
alkylation history of alcohol ingestion
a bunch of these to give you to nap
numbers okay and these numbers are
expert created based on scientific
studies one number tells you what is the
propensity of this person to have this
disease if they had the symptom other
one is telling you in a population how
what fraction the people will have this
finding if they had this disease okay
and using these two numbers you can
calculate a function that tells you what
is the possible diagnosis for this
particular patient and there has been as
I was saying there has been enough work
on this there's been one many such
diagnosis engine that was built but the
uptick was not that great because of
scale of radiations right because you're
generalizing these profiles you really
depend on on your studies so for
instance an example of this diabetes is
very common and in South Asian
population but that's that is something
that was studied recently so it's never
made it into this expert system so if
I'm a South Asian and I go to this to
with some conditions that are similar to
diabetes then I'm not going to be
recommended that because it's quite not
very common in another population it's
not very easy to personalize either okay
so but then the the spirit of having a
diagnosis model a spirit of assisting
doctors has always been there right from
the 1970s and recent work with
electronic health records the examples
that I showed you before there has been
a bunch of work on learning models for
diagnosis right where it's easier to
personalize you can combine multiple
data sources and there's no explicit
encoding of the problem so there's no
explicit encoding of expert knowledge so
you can take if you had access to
electronic health records a large amout
of them then you can possibly train a
model and use it and there are other
issues as well that I'll be happy to
talk about later so in a recent work
what we did was we had this notion of
how can you use these expert systems
that are built for like 30 years of
literature like pulling together and use
that as a prior for learning good models
for diagnosis so that you can deploy
them right so the basically the insight
here is that if you can have a clinical
simulator that can simulate a large
number of cases from these expert
systems then that gives you a training
data to train models on right so we had
a knowledge base we have a clinical case
simulator that simulates cases or any
say cases it's basically a configuration
of symptoms that lead up to that disease
right you can generate many such for
each one of these and then you get an
example you get these clinical vignettes
or cases
and then you can take these and train
your machine learned model for diagnosis
well you can pick your favorite one and
I'll be in the interest of time I'm not
gonna go over them but you can build
your own machine learning model the nice
thing about that is that if you look at
top on accuracy like oh what is the top
one differential that you can get just
from an expert system here at like
seventy five percent seventy percent and
if you're using a probabilistic
inference which is another technique
that you don't train a model you fix the
parameters go through the expert system
you know to a team but if you learn a
deep neural net you you get a very high
accuracy when you have not much noise
but it deteriorates later but then when
you inject noise and you train you get a
much better models so why is noise
important because when you are building
it into the user and out to the doctors
for instance users may choose not to say
certain symptoms because they think it's
not relevant right they may be the lemon
but you have your own biases oh that's
symptom I don't think that's relevant
for this particular problem that I'm
having right you skip a lot of these and
so like accounting for these noise that
you may have and that you do not have a
perfect system or inputs to the model
becomes very important and that's where
and so the way which in technology is
basically very medically sound we
actually talk to a lot of doctors on
what kinds of annoys makes sense and
then you can use that to train your
model injecting noises okay so and then
once you have this model it's very also
easy to incorporate clinical cases from
electronic health records you could go
back to your electronic health records
we have access to them and add more
clinical cases and this helps you to
increase the coverage of the diseases
you may have that's the number one thing
and the second thing is that it's going
to also help you with getting a
different phenotypes so same disease can
have different phenotypic manifestations
which are like different configuration
of the same same disease symptoms and by
having different data sources coming in
you have these different manifestations
that can be used
so we also touched briefly on multimodal
inputs so I'm going to like spend like a
few slides just a few slides on this so
here's an example of multimodal inputs
where the patient is actually giving you
an image of their health problems they
have something in the toe and they have
this conversation now you can ask how do
I use both of this information so even
in a primary care setting right you're
setting a large number of people go for
dermatological problems to the primary
care like 30% of the Kerman dermatologic
conditions are seen by a primary care
physician who probably have not who had
taken like a semester probably of
dermatology really so this is also
another place where you can actually
assist doctors as well and it's actually
a very long tail because you see a lot
more people with eczema and your data
set is going to have a lot more people
about eczema length flea bites for
instance and within each class is a huge
intraclass variability because your
eczema on your hand is very different
from that's on your face and so on so we
pose this as a few short learning setup
there the idea is that you want to learn
generalizable representations but you
have only small amount of training data
right so you have first during your
training you have the classes with many
samples but at test time you're also
given some classes but you also have
very small number of data and you need
to learn a classifier that can actually
learn to generalize and what we showed
and in a recent work is that you can
train a model called prototypical
clustering networks which is an
extension if you're familiar with
prototypical networks it's an extension
to that where every class has got
multiple representations for it so you
can see how it's Seema on your hand is
varied as a different representation
then I'm showing you it the closest
image to that in the leg so the acne is
different it and then menu inference
time if you're given an image you can
now look for the closest one in these
clusters and assign that but when you
wanted to combine modalities you could
use that image as your starting point to
get your set of initial diseases and
then use that information later to
actually start asking questions relevant
questions for it
okay so that how are we doing for time
so the so that sort of concludes that
sort of tells you how we can think about
these more building models for diagnosis
right you can imagine getting data
sources from different types from either
from an expert system or from electronic
health records and combining with data
such as these conversational data so
that you can actually learn a full space
of medical diagnosis really well and to
do that you also need to solve other
problems such as understanding patient
languages and so on so there are a bunch
of open challenges here one is the cost
of errors something that I've not talked
about is what's the cost of error right
how much if you make a mistake how much
does it cost then and how do we quantify
that and same thing with delayed delayed
treatments so if you delay your
treatment for a particular patient how
much is that gonna cost it's an
important component and it's something
that we should be thinking about as we
start to think about machine learning
into this mix then when you we touched
on this before like medically aware
conversational models there's an
importance of eliciting information in a
way that the patient will understand and
also being able to communicate these
outcomes right so that you know what the
next steps are and how and how do you
bridge those and the other part related
to cost versus diagnosis in the world so
if you look at icd-10 codes they're
about I don't know quite a few thousands
of diseases you probably don't have data
for all of them and when you train
models we assume that your test set is
going to have the same set of labels as
your training set and that is not the
case at all in healthcare right in any
in any setting like here like you have a
patient coming in with their symptoms
you it can always bucket them to one of
those classes that you have data for
because they may have a different
problem than what is there so diagnose
system the wall will become super
important and how do you even learn a
model that tells you that oh I don't
know how to actually find the diagnosis
for you right and say hey this is
something that I cannot solve for you or
there's something that I don't have much
information about you should
let me fall back to the doctor right so
it's notion of what's also very active
topic in machine learning it's a notion
of reducing I musta phobia which is
basically the fear of the unknowns how
do you understand reduce the fear of the
unknowns of things you have so you can
tell you tell go back in the model can
actually say I don't know it's a it's a
very active research but it's actually a
very important problem to small
especially in healthcare setup and
modelling causation so deep neural nets
or machine learning problems generally
today except probably Castle ground
inference does not model causation at
all right you have input you have
outputs you have input you you suggest a
series of actions to take right whether
it's a classification or an oil
framework but truly modeling causation
will become important and as symptoms
come in to be able to say hey this could
be predicted because of the medications
your nausea could be explained due to
the medication that you're taking so you
explain a not explained it away so that
the propensity of you having
gastroenteritis goes down right so being
able to do those sign of causal models
is going to be like super important and
I think that's also a place where we
should be spending a lot of time as a
community as well so that's all I have
except that so I truly believe that you
know everyone here has smartphone like
anywhere even in a very rural area and
even in an undeveloped underdeveloped
countries but we should have a care or
health care to be also mobile first it
should start from your mobile phone all
right and we need and to do that we need
the AI and the human practitioners on
the loop so for use the AI when you can
and then project it back to the
practitioners and you should know when
the AI system should also be capable of
saying I don't know so that you can
actually project it back to the human
practitioners as needed and have them
all in the loop and your cost I don't I
put in a number here of 20% but ideally
should health care should be free but
you know there's has to be some sort of
a metric on how you're measuring whether
you're making progress
I just gonna touch because I have some I
have a lot of time probably meant really
fast okay so let me just tell you a
little bit about Qri because I'm really
excited about it I've been here for like
two years pretty much from the start of
the company and I just love it first is
our mission is to scale the world's best
healthcare to everyone right so there's
a lower barrier to entry so anyone who
needs access to healthcare should have
access to healthcare and I think that's
where it is and we have a awesome and a
diverse team and diversity in terms of
experiences diversity in sort of
ethnicity gender and so on and we're
combining state-of-the-art ml with
product UX practices to build the best
product we can if you're if the space
interest you if any of this thing that I
told you interest you should just
definitely come and talk to me thank you
it was a short one hopefully you got
something out of it Thanks
thank you so much for working on this so
can you talk about essentially some of
the you know in the last two years
you've worked at this company like what
what are some of the business wins that
you guys have had so so the way we are
looking at this is a quite a bit of a
long term journey as opposed to saying
right from the first year where is my
business profit Thanks I think they will
that will come but it's not something
that thinking about but then that
doesn't mean that we are a research lab
either right I mean so you're looking at
a long term so one of the things we have
done to evaluate how well our learning
models do is to we had acquired this
company called first opinion what they
have been doing for three four years is
actually really a first opinion service
where they have a large number of
doctors who actually can have to whom a
user can go in just the who can sign up
and talk to the doctor for free of cost
and they have been collecting this data
for over like three four years so that's
a company that we are quiet and what we
are trying to do is as we build out our
models we are also interfacing some of
our models in front of the doctors to
see whether
doctor will accept our suggestions and
use that as our framework of thinking
about how to develop the models better
right so we don't want to go into the
business yet in terms because we really
think that the technology has to be
really good because if you are not
trying to do something that's like oh I
can just use the users likes and you
know sort of reshare to figure out how
well our model is doing I mean that
doesn't work in the space you really
need to be precise and so we have
strategy zones and evaluating how well
and metrics on how well we are improving
and so on but it's not something we are
actually at at this moment doing
anything I mean we have some thoughts we
have we have been thinking but we
haven't done I wouldn't say we have done
anything in terms of economics to sort
of say here are events
[Music]